[موسيقى]
ممنون لكثير اشياء في حياتي يعني اشياء
الحقيقه هي بسيطه جدا يعني بوقتها ما بقدر
كنت تفكر انه رح توديني لبعيد منها والد
بسيط يشتري لي دفتر رسم كان بالنسبه لهذا
الدفتر هو اهم شيء في حياتي وهذا الشيء
الحقيقه اعطاني دافع كبير انه ما يكون في
حياتي شيء غير الفن
اللي بمر فيه الفنان بالعموم هو زائد
افكاره هو تجاربه الاهم فيها انه انت شو
بدك تقولي يعني
اللوحه هي المجرد مساحه وبتنقل فيها
مشاعرك وبالتالي ما في عمل بشبه عمل
مستحيل والدليل انه حتى المشاهد احيانا
بشوف شيء انت مالك شايفه اصلا او انت مانك
قاصده حتى كفنان
دائما كان في موضوع امراه في في اعمالي
تروي تساؤلات عن الحياه عن الفرح عن الحب
عن الموت عن كل التساؤلات الوجوديه يعني
ولكن في النهايه بسبب ظروف الاوضاع
الفظيعه الحياه في سوريا يعني المعرض
الاخير كان
يعني كان صعب شو بدي اسميه حتى
كانت اول مره بشوف المراه بلد ولذلك تعبت
بعدها قدام حجم الماساه الحقيقه السوريه
طبعا
بضل سؤالك انه انت الفنان قدام حرب
بتقدر تصنع شيء او لا
[موسيقى]
نحن جينا على الحياه فتره ما رح نرضي حدا
ما رح تقدر
تصنع معجزات بمعنى الكلمه
وانما ممكن تترك اثر
[موسيقى]